hello everyone welcome to another
episode of
U Science and Technology Q&A for kids
and others um I'm still not back in my
natural habitat so not as quite as well
set up as usual but uh see what we can
do
here let's see I see a bunch of
questions that came
in there's one from
anonymouse can you explain dark matter
in layman's terms okay let's see what we
can do with
that
so
one of the things that so if you look at
a Galaxy for example what holds a Galaxy
together well it's gravity there are
gravitational attraction between the
stars and the Galaxy and like our
Galaxy's been around oh I don't know how
long has it been around probably I'm not
sure actually it's known but but um uh
certainly five six billion years at
least maybe longer than that um and the
Galaxy it's it's a our galaxy is a
spiral galaxy it's a fairly big Galaxy
and it's rotating around and it's
rotating at a certain rate takes a few
hundred million years I think to do a
rotation and uh uh the it's the thing is
not flying apart because it's held
together by the by the force of gravity
and it's like the stars on the outside
of our galaxy are rotating around the
center and they it's like they're
orbiting around the center of the Galaxy
and that's they're being held in their
orbits by gravity just like the Earth is
being held in its orbit around the Sun
by gravity so that's kind of how the
thing is set up and you might say well
gosh you know we know how gravity works
we have this formula this inverse Square
law of gravity that the strength of
gravity is proportional to one over the
square of the distance between things
and so on we know how all of that works
so we should be able to work out uh how
fast the Galaxy can be rotated and still
be held together with gravity and so on
we should be able to just work all that
stuff out okay so people starting 100
years ago tried to work those kinds of
things out and it didn't work out right
they said there's this amount of mass in
the galaxy and they can say well is this
amount of gas because look we can see
all the stars in the galaxy we know what
the typical masses of stars are the sun
is a fairly massive star on the on the
scale of of masses of stars there are a
lot of much much smaller fainter stars
in the galaxy there are also much bigger
stars in the Sun but the sun is kind of
on the on the upper end but we know
there are about 100 billion stars in our
galaxy and we know roughly what the kind
of number of stars is in different
regions of the Galaxy and we should be
able to work out uh kind of
how uh how the the amount of gravity
produced by those stars and what that
means for the possible rotation of the
Galaxy in particular What's called the
rotation curve which is
how much how fast are things rotating um
as a function of how far out from the
center of the Galaxy they are now one
thing that that has been known in more
recent times is that at the center of a
galaxy like ours there's essentially a
giant garbage dump a very big black hole
maybe 100 thousand times the mass of the
Sun that's gradually uh sort of eating
up stars and so on and if if we were
near the center of the Galaxy we're not
we're on the outer edge of the Galaxy um
It's kind kind of uh probably a good
thing we're not near the center of the
Galaxy because this big garbage dump is
coming through and eating up Stars near
the center of the Galaxy another feature
of near being near the center of the
galaxy is the density of stars is much
higher so in our night sky we see a
certain number of stars you see a
certain number of stars that are bright
because they're fairly near us if we
were at the center of the Galaxy our
night sky would be much more lit up so
to speak with stars there be just a lot
more stars nearby but in any case from
from all of this one could work out sort
of what's the what's the rotation that
you would expect in the Galaxy uh
relative to the distance from the center
of the Galaxy and by golly it didn't fit
well why not well the the idea is well
there must be something else in the
Galaxy that we're not seeing some kind
of dark matter the matter that is in
stars is sort of the Luminous matter
this the matter that's producing light
we can tell it's there CU it's it's
stars and they're shining um but there
must be something else some kind of dark
matter that is not um not visible in the
in the in the Galaxy so that was kind of
the first tip off then there are other
places where one can kind of see that
there's something we don't see that
still has a gravitational effect another
one there are two galaxies that collided
with each other and they kind of went
through each other but you can tell from
the from the motion of the things that
there's this sort of blob in the Middle
where there doesn't seem to be anything
there where it's still having
gravitational effect part of the way you
can tell that is by this phenomenon of
gravitational lensing so when when one
of the features of gravity is gravity
attracts everything everything that has
a um is is affected by the force of
gravity the way one thinks about gravity
in general altivity the kind of standard
theory of gravity is that gravity causes
a distortion in the structure of
SpaceTime gravity causes you can think
of it this way that without gravity the
shortest path between two points is a
straight line that if you and if you
shine a laser beam or something the
laser beam will always follow the path
of the shortest path in the direction
it's going so it will just be a straight
line but if you introduce gravity
gravity produces a curvature in
SpaceTime and that curvature just like
if you were to say I've got this curved
surface I've got this this dip in the
surface and I say what's the shortest
path from this place to that place
including the dip well you'll the that
path will not be straight anymore that
path will deflect as it goes through the
dip that will correspond to the shortest
path and so it is when there's gravity
that uh the the the shortest path is not
the straight line path and in fact the
we can think of gravity as being a way
of our way of describing the fact that
the shortest path is deflected so we can
describe that as the force of gravity we
can also say oh space time is curved and
and so or space is curved and so that's
why even though these things really are
following shortest paths the shortest
path is no longer a straight line well
that phenomenon of the way that gravity
Works affects not only you know
spacecraft in orbit around the Earth or
planets or stars in orbit around this or
that it also affects light and when one
goes when one has a a massive object
maybe a planet or the Sun or a
Galaxy Light is deflected by the force
of gravity associated with that object
and so that means for example light
traveling around the Sun is is Bent by
the presence of the of gravity
associated with the sun and that was
observed first observed in
1919 uh when there was a total solar
eclipse no doubt one will be able to see
it again in the April 8th of of of this
year's solar total solar eclipse uh if
you look at a star that's really close
to the Sun that is sort of obviously
behind the sun because the star is far
away and the disk of the sun is covered
by by the moon and so you get to see the
stars because the sky is not is not
there not just this burst of light from
the sun you get to see those Stars uh
and so you look at a star that's very
close to the edge of the Sun as you see
it in the sky um and now with the moon
blocking the sun you kind of look at
that star and you ask the question did
the presence of the sun move the
effective position of that star and what
was observed in 1919 probably not as
dramatic as people claimed at the time
but doesn't really matter was that yes
the um the the the effective position of
that that star is changed because the
light coming from that star is bent as
it went around the Sun and so that
phenomenon of of light is is sort of
pulled in as it goes around a massive
object that is the phenomenon of
gravitational lensing and when when
light goes through a a converging lens
like a convex lens a lens that bulges
out what happens is that light from uh
that's coming in lots of parallel rays
of light are coming in and that lens
will make those those rays of light
converge and for example come to a focus
and that's how for example when we look
at a distance and we are trying to look
at things that are far away the way that
those things get focused onto the retina
and our eye is that our the lens in our
eye is a converging lens and it it does
lensing so to speak to make light be be
bent and and uh and converge together
well the same thing happens with light
going around a Galaxy uh that there is a
lensing effect that sort of stars from
or galaxies that you see behind that
Galaxy the light from them is is sort of
pulled in now the really dramatic thing
is that you can end up with something
and these are really cool pictur
pictures you can end up with something
where there are multiple images of one
Galaxy there's a Galaxy behind some
Galaxy here and the light is bent and it
ends up that where we are there are the
light is bent going one way around that
galaxy in the middle and going the other
way around the galaxy in the middle and
you end up with two different images of
the Galaxy behind so that's a way and
you can kind of measure the amounts of
of gravity in that galaxy in the middle
by seeing how much of those images where
are where those images end up how much
gravitational lensing is there so that's
another way of kind of measuring mass
out there in in the
universe another thing that uh has where
you can kind of see the effects of kind
of mass is is from the cosmic microwave
background actually we don't need to
talk about that right now let's just say
there are places where there's stuff
that produces gravity but it isn't we
don't see it as luminous stars that's
what dark matter is what do we know
about dark matter what it might be
well it's kind of the very fact that
it's called dark matter means that we
think there's something there that is
some kind of matter likee thing it's not
completely obvious that's correct in
fact I suspect it isn't correct I
suspect that dark matter isn't matter at
all it's some feature of the structure
of space that we don't yet understand
now if you think think it's matter you
say what kind of matter what might it be
might it made little tiny black holes
might it be little particles that are
incredibly uh light relative to the
electron or something might it be what
might it be and there are some
constraints that that people have found
over the years of it can't be particles
that are that are too light they may
have to be you know it can't be
particles that are you know a a a
billion trillion times lighter than an
electron for example because if it was
it would have different effects in the
other Universe it can't be things that
are uh too massive in this way or
another
way another thing is it can't be
anything that interacts with ordinary
matter because we don't see something
where there's actual sort of uh uh
processes of interaction we don't see
for example uh particles that I don't
know electrons or something like that
going through these regions of dark
matter and and and scattering from them
and so on so the assumption is that if
it's that it must be some kind of matter
that interacts incredibly weakly and
there are all sorts of experiments that
involve trying to find particles
different kinds axons are one popular
possibility there are variety of others
that are um particles that occasionally
interact if they never interacted at all
except through gravity it'd be really
hard to detect their presence
but the idea is if you have a big enough
tank of water or something or you're
looking at some some region of uh um
underneath the ice in Antarctica or
something where everything is very still
then just occasionally maybe one of
these dark matter particles would hit a
particle of ordinary matter and interact
with it and that particle of ordinary
matter will be kicked by the Dark Matter
particle and it would be zooming off in
some direction and you'd be able to
detect that and a typical way you detect
it is with a thing called chanal
radiation which is something where if a
particle is is kicked so that it is
going faster than light goes in that
Medium so in in a vacuum light goes at
the standard speed of light but in
something like a piece of glass light
goes one and a half times slower than it
does in in the vacuum but you can have a
particle that proton electron whatever
else that was sort of pushed hard enough
that it's going faster it's going close
to the actual speed of light in the
vacuum and faster than the speed of
light as it exists in a piece of glass
or or water which will be 1.33 times
slower than than the speed of light in a
vacuum and when you have a particle
that's going faster than the local speed
of light it has this effect of producing
essentially a light shock front uh kind
of like a Sonic Boom for light like a
when you have a plane going faster than
speed of sound all the kind of air the
sound waves kind of pile up on the plane
and you get this kind of Sonic Boom you
get the same kind of thing with light
you get this kind of cone of light that
gets produced that's called trco
radiation typically bluish light and uh
you can detect that potentially you know
if you've got this big big area of water
deep under Antarctic or something and
there's uh there's nothing actually the
Antarctic cases is there an actual tank
of stuff that was put there but if you
if you have um uh in the ocean ious
places in the deep ocean I think there
was one near Hawaii I'm not sure if
that's still being experiment that's
still being done where usually there's
there's nothing that produces light but
you end up with uh with something that
suddenly produces this little flash of
light so in any case people have been
looking for these things there are a
large number of experiments that have
been done nobody's ever found anything
so my own guess is that one's looking in
the wrong place and that dark matter
isn't in fact matter at all it's not a
sort of unseen particles it's rather
some feature of the structure of space
not quite sure what feature of the
structure is bace I have some ideas let
me give an analogy though which I think
is perhaps useful in one of the things
that really mystified people in the
1800s was what heat is you know you have
a piece of material piece of metal or
something like this you heat it up we
know that heat can flow from one piece
of material to another you can have a
hot piece of metal next to a cold piece
of metal the heat will flow from the hot
piece of metal to the cold piece of
metal well what is the heat so people
said it must be a fluid it must be
something like water that somehow gets
into the pores inside the metal and when
you put the hot metal next to the cold
metal that that fluid that represents
heat they call it caloric fluid when
that fluid is there's more caloric fluid
in the hot metal than there is in the
cold metal so it will somehow flow from
the hot metal to the cold metal and
there were equations mathematical
equations that described how that worked
and those equations actually look very
much like the equations of fluid flow so
people said yep it must be a fluid well
nobody ever found caloric fluid and
turned out it wasn't a fluid after all
what is heat heat is the microscopic
motion of molecules heat is the when you
heat something up what's happening is
that the individual molecules are
bouncing around more quickly that's what
temperature for example is the average
rate at which those molecules are
bouncing around so heat is really a
feature of the microscopic structure of
the material not some kind of add-on
thing of oh we've got this caloric fluid
okay so what about Dark Matter well is
there an analogy there well depends what
what you think space is kind of the the
view of space that people have tended to
have is that space is just sort of a
background you just put things in
different places in space space isn't a
thing and and you might have said that
about you know water or something it's
just this background that can flow from
here to there but actually we know space
is made of stuff it's made of molecules
it's made of lots of little molecules
bouncing around hitting each other the
the the large scale effect of all those
molecules is to have something which
behaves like water but there is a
there's an underneath there's a bunch of
molecules there well I strongly suspect
that the same is true of space and that
space is kind of made of some discrete
elements that we can think of as being
sort of related to each other by some
kind of big Network and that that
network is is progressively changing
it's not like a mechanical collision
between sort of atoms of space it's more
a more abstract kind of process that
involves the relations between atoms of
space gradually being updated According
to some rule that we can think of as
kind of a computational rule and so we
built this whole model of physics that
seems to work remarkably well um that is
based on kind of this idea of a discrete
space and uh sort of the these rules
being applied to this network that
represents discrete space and if you ask
well you know what emerges it's kind of
like when you have a bunch of molecules
bouncing around underneath what emerges
is something a fluid like water what
emerges as the structure of space and
the answer is gravity and the things we
know about space so that's very
encouraging but now the question is well
are there features of space that we're
not kind of taking into account when we
look at this kind of large scale
structure of space that corresponds to
things like gravity well what else is
there about space one of the things I
kind of suspect is that there is what we
might call space-time heat that is that
the microscopic structure of space
associated with exactly how is this
network set up exactly what kinds of
updates happen exactly where in the
network work those things don't have an
effect on the sort of overall sort of
structure of space but they probably do
have some effect they have an effect
that probably changes the the amount of
gravity that's there the sort of Base
amount of gravity that's there and
possibly does so in a kind of way that's
a bit like dark matter so it would be
kind of an ironic thing if it turns out
that dark matter is actually a feature
of the microscopic structure of space
just like heat turned out to be a
feature of the microscopic structure of
materials and my my my somewhat guess is
that that's what dark matter is it has
nothing to do with matter of an ordinary
kind it's rather microscopic structure
of space and well what is matter in this
in this view a matter something like an
electron or a photon or a quark or
something like this in this view of of
the universe where everything is this
kind of giant network of atoms of space
a particle is some kind of big sort of
uh persistent object formed from pieces
of this network much like in a fluid you
can make a little Eddie that's a bunch
of mole bunch of fluid going around
that's formed from lots of underlying
molecules but there's kind of this large
scale uh kind of piece of the fluid that
has a certain persistence the Edie moves
through the fluid without change so
similarly that's what we suspect
particles are in our models of physics
so if Dark Matter was particles it would
be a bunch of sort of persistent large
scale large scale relative to sort of
atoms of space large scale kind of
excitations motions inside the structure
of space as opposed to space-time heat
which would be something much more
microscopic much less coherent not
formed into big big Blobby particles so
to speak so anyway that's that's that's
my guess about how it works and we'll
see maybe this year we'll we'll get some
sort of experimental implications of
that and we'll be able to actually tell
people use this telescope do this and
you'll see this weird weird phenomenon
and that's what dark matter is I I will
say that another related thing a bit
related to SpaceTime heat is the idea of
Dimension fluctuations you know we
believe we live in a
three-dimensional Universe with three
dimensions of space you know we go
forwards sideways up down but in fact in
our models this network that represents
space doesn't have to be exactly
threedimensional it could be 3.01
dimensional what does that mean it means
if if you say for example in three
dimensions you say you start from a
point you say how much stuff is there if
I go out a distance a certain distance
from that point well you know if you
know the formula for the volume of a of
a a sphere it's 4/3 pi R cubed and where
R is the radius well if if space isn't
threedimensional but it's 3.01
dimensional the corresponding formula is
the amount of stuff is R to the^
3.01 and it's we kind of suspect that
formulating kind of I talked about
gravity as being associated with the
curvature of space that actually you can
as well think about gravity as a feature
of small changes in effective dimension
of space and that that's sort of an
equivalent an alternate view of of
what's going on there and that
difference between sort of the view of
it in terms of cature the view of it in
terms of dimension change might have
something to do with sort of the changes
to sort of the the way gravity works
that would be that would account for
things like dark matter we don't know
yet still still uh up up in the air just
trying to um something we'd like to
figure
out
um let's
see uh
uh okay IP asks could dark matter just
not be interacting with light and
photons um yes that's I mean many of the
models of dark matter just say it's
particle well I think it can not be
interacting both with with light and
with other kinds of things because
there's lots of gas in the interstellar
medium in galaxies and things like that
and you would expect to see if there was
sort of interactions between that and
dark matter you would expect to see some
kind of effect on the gas and that isn't
seen
uh let's
see
um Kathy asks if our universe is
accelerating faster than the speed of
light does that mean we cannot see
anything past that past the speed of
light well so this is a complicated mess
this question about sort of just how
fast is our universe expanding and uh
how does that all work one of the things
that there are sort of equations that
describe the effective size of the
universe but it's not like when you hit
the edge of the universe you fall off
it's it's more complicated than that
because the universe is expanding but
let's say we try to reach the edge well
we at most we can go at the speed of
light and there's sort of this question
about do we reach the edge and are we
reaching the edge at the point where the
universe is sort of expanded past that
edge in the end it's a it's a sort of
thing that you can best describe with
the kind of math associated with kind of
the the the sort of the the the
structure of space it's it's a weird
thing because that you're describing all
of space and that's the only place you
can go so it's not like you'd say well
you know there's an edge and you reach
that edge and there's nothing there
that's not how things work it's more
like if you're on a sphere for example
and you say let's just keep going oh do
I reach the edge of the sphere if I'm a
little creature on the surface of the
sphere no I don't at worst I go back
around and come back around the sphere
but I never reach the edge of the sphere
that's just not a concept that is is a
thing in the case of the surface of a
sphere so in the expansion of the
universe one of the questions is so at
the beginning of the universe there was
a we think of it as a big bang the
universe just started going outwards
started expanding at a certain rate well
one feature is the universe has stuff in
it and that stuff has mass which
produces gravity so what you might
expect is that the Universe would it
would expand out for a while and then
the force of gravity would like pull it
pull it pull it back and eventually it
would get the the expansion of the
universe would reverse and the universe
would start coming back and eventually
there'd be a big crunch to go along with
a big bang and a long time from now so
to speak that's one possibility another
possibility is there's kind of just
enough sort of outward motion associated
with the big bang that just keeps going
and eventually it's just sort of
coasting out at a certain a certain rate
that is basically the speed of light
another possibility is that there's
something gravity is a force that just
always pulls things together imagine
there was anti-gravity imagine there was
a force that could push things apart
well if that was happening in the
universe the universe could be perhaps
accelerating in in how fast it was
expanding well there's this weird idea
Dark Energy dark energy is basically
matter with negative mass and matter
with negative Mass has the feature that
instead of producing an attractive force
of gravity it produces a repulsive force
of gravity now we don't know that matter
with negative Mass exists we don't know
that anything with negative Mass exists
it's probably not matter people say oh
that's not really matter because matter
is something with positive Mass but a
something with negative uh negative mass
now it gets very tricky because when you
say there's a thing there that has
negative Mass well okay when you say
there's nothing there turns out in
theories of physics for the last 100
years it's not been possible to have a
situation where there's truly nothing
there where there's truly a quotes
vacuum with abs absolutely nothing there
and that's because there are always
Quantum
fluctuations in in quantum mechanics one
of the features of of it is to say you
never know exactly what's going on
there's always a multiple possibilities
and there's always certain probabilities
of different things happening and so it
is with knowing you say there are no
particles here well quantum mechanics
says you'll never be able to say that
you'll always have some uncertainty in
the number of particles and so that
means that that you've always got kind
of in the in what would normally be the
the vacuum you've got this sort of
bubbling of of particles they're virtual
particles that are coming into existence
particles and anti particles they're
coming into existence for a short time
then getting destroyed and this is
happening all over the universe all the
time I have to say that in our models of
physics is a little bit cleaner what's
happening but that's the that's the
traditional view in our models of
physics the the structure of space is
this network and in a sense what holds
together that network is the fact that
every piece of the network is
continually being updated so if you say
I've got two atoms of space and are they
continuing to be related to each other
are they continue to even be connected
in Space the answer is what makes them
continue to be connected is that they're
constantly being Rewritten that the sort
of network around them is constantly
being Rewritten those very atoms of
space are constantly being Rewritten but
you can always say can I get from this
place to that place well yes because
there are these rewrites that are
happening that are kind of making this
change this change this change all the
way along some line so that you can
always get from one place to another and
that's kind of what keeps the universe
together it knits together the structure
of space so in our models of physics
most of the activity of the universe is
about knitting together the structure of
space that's most of what's happening in
the universe everything that we care
about is a tiny little piece of fluff on
top of all this activity knitting
together the structure of space so for
example it might be let's say one one in
10 to the 120 or something so one in in
uh one part in a trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion
trillion of what's happening in the
universe is all the stuff we care about
and most of it is just knitting together
the structure of space so in sort of
traditional view of physics something
rather similar happens except it's a bit
Messier and a bit harder to understand
and doesn't really quite work it's this
virtual particle thing these vacuum
fluctuations one of the things that's
always been embarrassing about those
vacuum fluctuations is that the vacuum
fluctuations are associated with a
certain amount of mass if there was that
much mass in the universe ACC when you
sort of separate out the theory of
gravity from the theory of quantum
mechanics you get the implication that
all this quantum mechanical stuff that's
making this effective mass at every
place in space would also produce
gravity and that gravity would be so big
that it would curl the universe up into
a tiny ball and well we're here the
universe isn't curled in that tiny ball
so something went wrong with that
picture in our models nothing like that
happens because all those little effects
which in quantum mechanics will be in
standard quantum mechanics will be
interpreted as vacuum fluctuations those
are all part of this phenomenon of how
SPAC is knitted together and so the fact
that and gravity is part of that too so
it's not that there are two separate
things where one has a bizarre effect on
the other these are two things that all
go together that's all associated with
nitting together the structure of space
So Okay so we've got space and we've got
this vacuum fluctuations we've got this
nitting together of the structure of
space and we've got um so now the
question is well what happens if there's
a piece of space where there are few
fewer vacuum fluctuations or a piece of
space where there's somehow less
knitting well then that would correspond
to a piece of space that effectively has
less mass and relative to the rest of
space if we say the or most of space we
say oh it has zero Mass because it's
just what we call vacuum then the places
where there's kind of less activity will
have will appear to have negative Mass
so that's kind of a a picture of how you
would get something like dark energy now
you could have you could have other
phenomena that lead to that there's kind
of a a big hack in in current physics to
do with the higs particle and the origin
of mass in current physics oh heck I can
explain that I suppose so okay let's
this is a bit of a this is the sideshow
of of how does how does current physics
account for the fact that particles like
electrons and so on have non-zero Mass
photons have zero Mass um and and this
is going to be related to you you'll see
how it's related to this whole question
about negative Mass things and so on
okay so so here's how it works when you
make a Theory of physics the in the most
elegant mathematical approach is a thing
called the local gauge Theory and
essentially what happens there is you
say uh you're kind of saying at
different places in the universe you say
that things are set up
in you you're you're kind of describing
what's happening in a way that may be
different in different places so for
example if you say what's a good example
here if you say
um at every place in space I'm going to
say there's a quantity that is somewhere
on a circle so it's at some angle on the
circle and we say it's 30° at this place
in space it's 60° at that place in space
it's 20 degrees at that place in
space well at any local place in space
you just say you don't know what what
angle it's at because you have no way to
measure it all you can tell is it's at a
different angle in this place in space
than it is in that place in space and so
th this question about how do the angles
relate between sort of the the what it's
like in this place in space and what
it's like in that place of space the
relation between those angles is
associated with a thing called the
connection and the connection is kind of
what tells you how does the angle in
this place connect to the angle in that
place so we just we took all of space
and we just said we're putting down
these different angles in different
places now this is not quite as abstract
as I'm making it sound because when we
think about
electromagnetism you can say
electromagnetism ass is associated with
essentially an arbitrary choice of of
what amounts to an angle how does this
work okay A little bit of kind of in
electromagnetism there's this idea of of
a voltage what is the what is the we we
say uh in standard electricity and so on
we say this place is at such and such a
voltage that place is at such and such
another voltage when you have a 9volt
battery what it means is that the
difference in voltage the difference in
in um uh um electric potential between
the two poles of the battery is 9 volts
volts is a measure of you can think of
it as a it's a measure of of electric
potential and it's saying there's a 9vt
difference between the positive pole and
the negative pole and that 9vt
difference that voltage difference is
something which for example pushes
electrons in one way or another so it
pushes electrons through wires makes an
electric current that's what the battery
does okay but the choice of what um uh
the um the choice of what um um what we
say we say okay one side of the battery
it's set 7 112 volts well the only thing
we know is the other side of the battery
is 9 volts different from that we don't
know that the absolute voltage doesn't
really mean anything the only thing that
means something is the voltage
difference and so that idea kind of
translates itself into saying well at
every point in space you could say
there's a voltage but all that matters
is the difference of voltages between
these different places in space and the
the question is sort of how does one
place in space kind of if you um uh you
know how how do you relate the sort of
the voltages effectively in different
places in space and one one way to think
about that is let's imagine that you
have this voltage arranged in space and
suddenly you change yeah I should say
when there's a when there's a a
difference in voltage the you can
represent that Difference by an electric
field and you can kind of say when
there's a
um yeah roughly what what's going to
happen is we've got one place where
there's lots of voltage another place
where there's low voltage there's an
electric field that uh kind of is is
produced between those two two different
two different uh uh places well let's
say we make a change in the voltage in
one of these places and that's got to
change the electric field
because the the when we change the
voltage here it means the difference
between the voltage here is is different
and now the electric field will change
okay so we make that change somewhere
and now the question is so the electric
Field's got to change how fast does the
electric field change we make a change
here and somehow 10 miles away
eventually the fact we made this change
here has to somehow propagate out to
have an effect 10 miles away well
doesn't do it instantaneously how does
it do it well it does it at the speed of
light it does it there's a kind of wave
of change that propagates out that wave
of change is is essentially an
electromagnetic wave and the fact that
there has to be the sort of wave of
change is the reason that photons exist
in this picture it's the reason you have
to have something that's sort of a
carrier you can think of it as a carrier
of change where it's sort of telling the
rest of the universe that oh there was a
change in this voltage and so it is a
necessary feature of that this idea of
oh there's a voltage and it's sort of
arbitrary that's sometimes called the
gauge and you can make these different
choices of gauge the the difference
between Cho gauge in different places
has a measurable effect it's something
like an electric field because there's
this difference in voltage but then the
question is as you as you make a change
in that gauge how does that change in
gauge uh kind of how does it how does
the of the universe get to know about
that change and the answer is you have
to
have this is so-called gauge Fields like
photons that are kind of the carriers of
that change uh boy that's a pretty
abstract set of things and I I actually
think I did okay at explaining that
because that's a you know for for those
who um might be interested there's this
whole notion of a covariant derivative
when you say there's a change that's
happening you can say there's a change
in the in the um in the field and well
maybe it's not worth saying this it's
there's a change in this electric
potential and well okay you have to kind
of include this this this this change in
conventions and that's associated with
this connection thing but anyway bottom
line is connection field connection this
sort of carrier of change is something
like a photon one feature of those
carrying carry things that carry change
is they have to have zero Mass that's
just a feature of the way the math works
out is that that sort of wave of change
it always goes at the speed of light and
it always effectively has zero Mass like
a
photon uh however in in that kind of
setup one would start concluding well
everything in the universe has to have
zero Mass but whoops it doesn't
electrons don't have zero Mass quarks
don't have zero Mass Etc uh and so how
do you get Mass into the picture well it
turns out that the mathematical theory
of zero Mass gauge Fields is very
elegant it has all kinds of nice
features it there are all sorts of
Infinities that often show up they don't
show up quite the same way there you can
get rid of them So-Cal renormalizable
Theory um it uh uh you know it's all
good but then there's this ugly thing
that actually in the universe there's
Mass okay so there was this chap called
Peter higs along with a couple of other
people um who in the in the early 60s um
uh had this idea kind of a hack actually
and the idea was
imagine that you have something which
would normally be zero Mass but that
thing interacts with something else and
it interacts with what what we'll call
it the higs field it interacts with this
kind of background thing and it keeps on
you know it's just going happily along
but it actually is always being kicked
by the fact that there's a sort of a
background field okay now now normally
if you just have let's say electrons and
photons they interact with each other
just aren't very many electrons around
there aren't many many very many photons
around so most of the time it's like oh
yeah they you know electron hits a
photon or whatever and the electron is
deflected and it's all good and and it
just sort of happens once and you only
have to take account of it very rarely
so to speak but let's imagine instead in
this higs field it's a particle as well
but let's imagine that the whole
universe is full of higs field that in
some way there's a a kind of it's it's
like there's a a condensate like instead
of there being Hig particles and a gas
that just bouncing around very um uh
very sparsely um the U let's imagine
that um uh that the um uh that that
there's a that it's like a liquid that
it condensed that there's just higs
particles everywhere they're just you
know the whole universe is full of
densely filled with higs particles okay
if that's the case and your little
electron which was massless keeps
interacting with these higs particles it
will keep on kind of it will keep on
kind of getting slowed down by oh I had
to interact with the particle oh it kind
of bounced me this way or it bounced me
that way that effect of that process
will end up being um giving the electron
an effective Mass it gives the it's it's
the fact that there's this higs
condensate this kind of uh uh everywhere
is will make the electron have a mass so
you went from this thing where the
electron really has zero Mass but
because there's this higs condensate
everywhere it is it keeps which it keeps
on interacting with it's slowed down by
that and it effectively has a non-zero
Mass okay so
then uh that's that's all good but the
question is and that allows one to sort
of say well where's where does mass come
from that's where mass comes from okay
well how did there come to be this higs
condensate thing well there you have to
assume that there's a self- interaction
between higs particles but the higs
particles like the fact that if you have
particles in a in I don't know a water
for example the the molecules of water
interact with each other they're kind of
attracting each other and that's how you
get liquid water as opposed to just
water molecules floating around and just
not really paying attention to each
other the fact that they form this
condensate they form this condensed
water where everybody's gotten together
that's a consequence the fact that they
have self interactions and I think that
the um uh the thing that um uh that so
there's this assumption that the higs
field has the self- interaction and that
things work out just so that there's a
certain condensate certain density of hi
particles in the universe I always
thought this was just a total hack but
as soon as you know that they are higs
particles and they form this condensate
and so on that means you should be able
to get a situation where there's just
one isolated higs particle somewhere and
eventually in the large heton collider
uh Hig particles were discovered um as
isolated higs particles and they have a
definite Mass um 120 times the mass of
the proton I think roughly um and um
right I think so uh 125 I think um the
um uh I used to when I was a kid I was I
was into the masses of all the
elementary particles I could I could
quote you all those masses that existed
at that time but uh I haven't paid
attention as well since then and um so
so I'm a little less less up to my
precise quot of of the numbers for these
things but any case higs particles were
discovered so some part of this picture
is like we know it's it's there's
something there the fact that this
condensate forms is just a hack it's
just a let's assume these particles
interact with each other it will form
this condensate okay one feature of that
is that means there's a thing throughout
the Universe the universe is full of
higs particles higs field at least and
when I say particles a particle is more
like an is ated sort of exitation sort
of it's like the Eddie in the in the
fluid whereas the the sort of the the
underlying field is like the whole fluid
itself so in any case the thing that um
uh happens is well a little bit like
liquid water if you heat it up
eventually there isn't a condensate
anymore eventually it turns to steam and
the same exact thing happens with the
higs condensate if you heat it up enough
eventually no longer condenses like that
and there isn't a high density of higs
field so in the early Universe when
things were hotter there was a um uh
there was the the the higs field no
longer formed the condensate if you go
back early enough less than um uh what
is it maybe a microsc after the
beginning of the universe there won't be
there wouldn't one wouldn't expect this
condensate to exist well what what
effect do does that have well this
condensate has a bunch of mass
associated with it it's just a whole
bunch of particles so it's a bunch of
mass so that means that the the uh sort
of underlying the the the mass the
effective Mass everywhere in the
universe is much lower earlier on than
it is later on and in fact one of the
things I noticed with a friend of mine
back in when was it
1978 was if that happens in the early
Universe there's this period of time
time when there isn't a big density of
mass which produces gravity which which
prevents the universe from expanding so
quickly instead the presence of the if
you get rid of that the Universe expands
incredibly quickly in fact it expands
exponentially quickly um and so at that
point where it's sort of an uncancelled
expansion like that you get this very
rapid expansion of the early universe
and that turned into later on the
inflationary scenario for the early
Universe which which I now think is kind
of nonsense but um uh that was uh that
was one of the sort of pieces of
personal scientific history I I you know
we had noticed this phenomenon but for
various reasons uh I just didn't think
it could be a significant enough
phenomenon in the history of the
universe because in order for it to be
significant it would have to be the case
that it would be as if one took Steam
and made it colder colder colder and
made it incredibly incredibly cold and
it still hadn't turned into water and
and it it would have to have be cooled
by a factor of of a billion um and not
turn into water and for various reasons
that didn't seem plausible because there
didn't seem like in order for that to
happen you have to not have any sort of
uh density changes in the material and
so on didn't think that would happen for
the universe but but later on people
said look it's such a cool effect that
you can get this exponential expansion
that uh it has to be the case that you
know that something must work out okay
with respect to this super cooling
phenomenon and that led to a lot of
complicated scenarios that I think are
very patched and so on I think the
actual story there about the early
universe and its expansion has to do
with more with the change of dimension
of the universe that the Universe
started infinite dimensional and then
gradually kind of kind of cooled down to
be three-dimensional and that accounts
for lots of phenomena that have required
all sorts of weird patches in the in the
existing theories okay I which is to all
to say that if you want to get Negative
Mass stuff one way to get it this higs
condensate thing is one way to get it
that normally there's higs condensate
and it leads to the masses of electrons
and things like that but for example if
there's a high temperature then that
condensate gets sort of uh evaporated
away and you have lower mass density
everywhere in the universe which shows
up as relative to the usual Baseline of
the universe shows up as negative Mass
so that's that's another example of how
that kind of thing works out okay what
happens if there's negative mass in the
universe well the expansion of the
universe accelerates and that means that
relative to us at some particular place
in the universe there are parts of the
universe that are effectively receding
from us fast in the speed of light so
we'll never know what happened to those
parts of the universe it's as if the
universe sort of Tears itself apart and
there are there are pieces where we just
don't know what's going to happen to
them because you know you you might have
you you might be sending exchanging
radio signals and the thing that's
exchanging the radio signals the radio
signals will never get to you very
similar to what happens in a black hole
it's in fact a very similar kind of
Event Horizon phenomenon where inside a
black hole that radio signal was trying
to get out it's being pulled back by
gravity and that radio signal will never
get out and it's the same type of thing
here it's because of this thing called
principle of equivalence equivalence
between gravity and acceleration there's
a very close correspondence between
these things and you just never get the
signal so to speak so there are parts of
the universe we never hear
from well anyway I think I think that
the
um
uh yeah there there's some question here
about um from LLY about is the viscosity
of the higs field what gives Mass to
particles it's not quite viscosity
unfortunately it's it's some let me
explain it a little bit okay so in light
in a vacuum goes at a certain speed
about 300 million meters per second in a
material like water goes slower water
it's 1.33 times slower glass 1.5 times
slower I mentioned that earlier in quite
different context why does that happen
well what's happening is in the material
Like Water for example the light goes
into the water the photon of light keeps
on hitting water mole ules every time it
hits a water molecule there's the water
molecule says Okay I I just got I I got
kicked by this Photon I'm going into an
excited state I'm I'm uh I've I've got
energy sort of inside the atom and after
a little while that energy the atom says
oh no I want to get rid of that energy
again I imit another Photon so Photon
comes in excites the atom then the atom
takes a little while to decide it's
going to Reit the photon onward and the
reason that light is going slower in
these materials is because the photons
are continually getting absorbed and
reemitted absorbed and reemitted and the
amount that they're getting absorbed the
amount of slow down is not very great in
the case of those materials in Diamond
for example it's factor of
2.7 in the Sun for example the density
of material is high enough that a photon
from the center of the sun will take I
think it's 10 million years to get to
the surface so it's continually being uh
absorbed remitted absorbed reemitted
just keeps on keeps that keeps on
happening and the density of material is
high enough that it really slows it down
a lot so what's happening with with uh
particles like electrons in the higs
field is more or less a phenomenon like
that that what's happening is that the
the with relative to this higs field the
electron is coming along it keeps on
interacting with the higs field and it's
not quite an an absorption reemission
Story the uh the sort of official
version of this um gosh let me see if I
can reduce the math to something more
like this I mean the H the official
version okay just to say the words
there's a s called the lanan the lran
is it's both a representation of energy
and it's also the thing that is the
thing that appears in the formula that
tells you how things progress with time
in quantum mechanics the path integral
um oops
the and um
so uh so let's see how does how does
this work the um uh this is this is
going to get mathy and Technical
um when you represent a particle in this
lran you have a formula it's the
derivative of the field associated with
the particle all square
and plus the mass squ times the um
uh uh yeah Mass squared times the um the
particle field squared uh why am I
telling you all of this well because the
term that's associated with mass is mass
squar time field squared and what
happens is the interaction between the
higs field and a particle field like
let's say the electron field is called P
there's a um uh
um now let's see this is a little tricky
okay let's roughly um there's a mass
squi squar term and when you have
interaction with the higs field it
becomes a fi for the higs field squared
P Squared term and so what happens is
the um it's a little tricky because
anyway never mind footnotes to this
whole story but roughly what happens is
when you say there's a a condensate of
higs field that F squar which would
normally be the higs field that's
wiggling around doing all kinds of
things changing in position with the
position in space and so on that thing
is just a constant associated with the
density of higs field and so that's the
that's the thing that masquerades as a
mass because it's just that thing that
appears in that formula it it plays the
role of a mass even though it really is
not a mass it's really just the the
density of that field roughly the that's
that's roughly how it
works
so let's see alexand
Alexander
um asks how might the topological
stability and quantization of skons
initially proposed as models for
nucleons relate to our understanding of
gravity considering their presence in
solid state physics okay so this is
going this is this is jumping to a a
higher Tech techical level of of
elaboration but a skiron is something a
little bit like an Eddie in a fluid it's
something where once you've got that
Eddie going you can't kind of get rid of
the Eddie without you can kind of slow
down the Eddie but you can't just say oh
I'm going to sort of undo the Eddie
because there's pieces of fluid that
going one way and going the other way
around that core and they don't they you
can't get them to just sort of cancel
out it's kind of like you have a you
have a piece of string and you've have
wound it around a pencil you can't you
know you pull on the ends of the piece
of string it's still going to be wound
around the pencil you have to make a a
sort of discrete change to unwind it
around the pencil and that's what's
called topological stability it's
topology because it it relates to kind
of the not the detailed geometrical
position it doesn't really matter
whether the string is aligned this way
or that way it's just the overall
structure like topology is about
something like you can have a sphere or
you can have a dut with a hole in it
that always confused me because when I
was growing up in England Donuts have
Jam injected into the middle of them
it's only American donuts that have
holes in the middle of them
intrinsically made so the dut is like a
Taurus and when I read read things when
I was a kid that talked about donuts and
um that had holes in them it's like I
don't understand what's going on because
the donuts that I get in uh doughnut
places just have Jam injected into to
this thing that is basically a sphere
okay but independent of that an American
donut has is a Taurus with a with a hole
in in the middle so to speak and the
point is that you can't continuously go
from the you have to kind of rip if if
you've got doughnut material if you got
a blob of whatever dough the doughnut is
presumably made of um and you want to
turn it into a donut with a hole in it
at some point you have to rip the dough
you can't just continuously deform it to
go from the no hole to the whole
situation and so that that's kind of the
the concept of topology is this you can
you can W wiggle it around that's sort
of the geometry changing but you can't
change this sort of overall how many
holes does it have cut type structure
and so on and that that whole idea shows
up in all sorts of places for example in
our models of physics we we believe that
there's a similar kind of topological
phenomenon something where sort of the
overall structure the overall kind of uh
uh arrangement of things is such that
you get something that represents a
particle so skons are a particular
version of that for a particular model
of of um uh of
how uh how a field fluid is like a fe so
fluid there are lots of kinds of things
that we describe as fields in a fluid
you're looking at this fluid and it's
got It's got all these pieces but the
thing that's important is it has a
certain velocity
has a certain speed in a certain
direction at every place in the fluid
and you say that that's the velocity
field of the fluid and what happens in a
in in an Eddie for example is that the
velocity field has this kind of
topological stability to it it can't get
rid of that circulation that it has scon
a more elaborate version of a field and
that's a case where and and they were a
model at one point for things like
protons that model didn't pan out out
but this this general idea that things
that are stable are stable because they
are topologically stable because there's
something you just can't get rid of some
some kind of dut hole that you can't get
rid of that's some uh that that's that's
kind of the
thing uh all right I should wrap up soon
here but um let me
see uh Healey asks can the probability
of a random walk returning to the origin
be another way of defining local
dimension on a graph right again quite
technical let me just unpack that just
for fun um okay what is a random
walk
so let's say you are you're on a line
and you can take a step up you can take
a step down and let's say that you flip
a coin at every moment to say am I going
to take my next step up or down up down
up down Etc and you're always flipping a
coin you say well where do I get to well
you get all these Wiggly curves and
they'll keep going up and then they'll
come down and etc etc etc and they
wiggle around and you can say what's the
average distance that this curve goes
away from how far are you typically away
from from zero if zero is in the middle
and you're W you're you're randomly
going up or going down and the answer is
your average distance is about the
square root of the number of steps
you've taken the average the overall
distribution of how far you got is
so-called gaussian distribution normal
distribution it's a distribution it's
kind of a bell curve it's something that
shows up all over the place and as so
the random walk has this feature that
that's the average distance you've gone
now the question is if you go up and
you're wiggling up and you're wiggling
up you keep on doing hitting heads heads
heads heads heads and you get Tails
Tails tailes Tails tals one feature of
random walks says that anything that
comes up goes down again every random
walk eventually gets back to where every
random walk in in one dimension just
going up and down eventually gets back
to zero again and that's a phenomenon
that is uh people talk about uh in the
following way let's say you're you're
you're betting based on coins and you
say I'm ahead I'm ahead I'm I'm I'm
winning I'm winning I've got a zillion a
run of of heads and I'm I'm just going
to win I'm going to keep betting I'm
going to keep betting Well turns out
it's the phenomenon it's called gamblers
ruin eventually you're going to lose
because eventually that random walk is
going to come right back to zero again
eventually you're going to have enough
tales that you get right back to zero
again in one dimension it's guaranteed
that a random walk if you keep going
long enough you'll always hit zero again
so it's never a good thing to you you
can that that's kind of like even though
you thought you were ahead you're going
to be tailed down again so to speak um
and and reach
zero that's true in one
dimension in two dimensions a random
walk on a square grid for example has a
certain probability to return to the
origin in three dimensions a random walk
chances are it'll never return to the
origin chances are it'll just keep
wandering around and it'll just keep
wiggling around and going where it goes
and it'll never get back to the origin
again and there's a a critical Dimension
which I should know and I don't for uh
when well I I think it depends on the
kind of grid you're on actually and that
that is something you can't really
Define outside of an in number of
Dimensions um the uh let's
see well I'm not quite sure there's a
there's a notion of I mean fancy words
upper critical Dimension there's a thing
called the renormalization group which
is a way of analyzing kind
of things like these kinds of random
processes anyway that a bunch of fancy
stuff which I can't immediately unravel
for myself so I don't know the answer to
whether there's
a in in if you say one dimension two
dimensions three dimensions there are
definite things that happen if you say
if you could make something 2.5
dimensional what would it be like now
there are many in these graphs that we
have that represent kind of the
structure of space in the universe it's
sort of the first time where we have a
robust way of talking about fractional
Dimensions these things things called
fractals these nested patterns they're a
rather specific way of talking about
fractional dimensions and it doesn't
quite quite work generically there but
so there may be something which I there
may very well be something yes yes yes
that there will be yes in fact there is
okay so so yes the it is right that you
could think about sort of take a random
walk on this graph the graph has a
certain effective Dimension which you
can associate with well you start to
point how many points do you get to by
going a certain distance out and that uh
that is closely related to the question
of well how what's the probability that
you come back on the random walk and
that in turn is related to if you had
heat uh you have the equation for heat
is the diffusion equation that that's
actually the the diffusion equation the
way to think about it is instead of one
random walk just wiggling around here
you say start a very very large number
number of random walks what is the what
is the density of of where all those
different random walks will reached
that's the thing that gives you the
gaussian distribution the bell curve and
and it does that in any number of
Dimensions there's a there's a kind of
an analog of that in any number of
dimensions and so there is even INF
fractional dimensions and and I think
that will that's closely related to this
random walk thing and I think to the
return time of random walks which gives
you the um uh the kind of um things the
of coming back to the origin but there's
a bit of random workology there that I
can't in real time decode and would have
to think more carefully about
it
uh all right let's
see
one
um
gosh
all right I'll try one more and then we
should wrap up for
today uh from tud saying I'm quite
confused with heat and temperature and
the general introduction of
thermodynamics in this term in
school well not sure how totally much I
can help with that but um I'll
try uh what is heat what is
temperature so
when you have a material it's made of
molecules and the
molecules
are well they're typically wiggling
around they're bouncing around maybe
it's a gas they bounce until they hit
another molecule maybe it's a solid
they're always wiggling around close to
their usual position but they're always
wiggling around a bit okay the when they
when they wiggle around they're moving
they have a certain kinetic energy they
have a certain energy of motion
so in in the standard kind of way things
are set up if they have a a velocity V
their kinetic energy is half mv^ s where
m is their Mass so anyway there's a
there's an energy associated with that
motion and um that energy there's little
microscopic motion of all of these uh
molecules whether it's in a gas where
they move maybe a m a millionth of a
meter before they hit another molecule
whether maybe it's a a solid where they
move only a uh a billionth of a
before they get stopped and they could
have to go back the other way type thing
but in any case they're they're all
wiggling around okay so that amount of
wiggling around there's an average
amount of wiggling around that these
molecules do that average amount of
wiggling around is determined by the
temperature in fact there's a formula it
says that if you take the average
kinetic energy the um uh associated with
these molecules it's a constant called
boltzman's constant multiply by the
temperature and then there's a three
halves that we won't talk about for a
second um but but basically the um well
actually I can say it in every direction
the molecule might be wiggling so like
if there's three dimensions of space
every Dimension there's three three
directions it might be wiggling every
wiggling Direction the amount of energy
is a half times KT where K is boltzman's
constant and T is the temperature okay
so temperature is defined in terms of
the average kinetic energy of the
molecules wiggling around now okay how
do you measure temperature there well
it's important that there if you reduce
the temperature enough eventually you
get to the point in principle where the
molecules aren't wiggling anymore there
is no kinetic energy the kinetic energy
is zero what temperature is the kinetic
energy of molecule zero well the answer
is it's at the absolute zero of
temperature and it's-
273.16 degrees centigrade is absolute
zero at that temperature the then all
the kinetic energy is gone there's no
kinetic energy that's making the
molecules wiggle around okay footnote
because of these Quantum fluctuations
that I actually mentioned earlier um um
the there is still kinetic energy even
at Absolute Zero associated with quantum
mechanics and that means that well in
the particular example of of of helium
helium 4 helium 4 is still a liquid at
absolute zero because of quantum effects
but most of the time most materials are
just solids because all of their atoms
are just locked in place not moving so
in a first approximation in sort of the
the simplest way of thinking about the
theory at Absolute Zero of temperature
there is no kinetic energy every body is
just locked in place not moving okay so
then you uh you you add so when you add
add okay so K average kinetic energy
molecules is proportional to temperature
okay what's heat heat is the total
energy of all those molecules so you got
a big block of metal and every
individual molecule is wiggling around a
certain amount it has a certain average
kinetic energy but when you take all of
those energies put together you add them
all up then you get the total heat
energy associated with that block of
metal and those things are related by
thing called the specific heat that
tells you the amount of heat per
per degree of temperature so to speak so
as you increase the the average kinetic
energy of those individual molecules
you're increasing that and there's a
there's a certain number of molecules in
the in the block of metal or whatever it
is and then that is with a certain
there's a certain mass of the metal
depending Etc that constant of
proportionality is the so-called
specific heat so as you put heat into
the material so now here's where things
get tricky how do you put heat into a
material well you know one thing you
might do is just rub the material back
and forth you might have friction or
something or you might you know does it
make does it put heat in if you say let
me take this big block of metal and let
me throw it at high speed the big block
of metal has a certain kinetic energy
and you might say well I put energy into
this block of material but doesn't heat
the block of material up so just throw
it doesn't heat it up the heat heating
it up would be you've got microscopic
motion of molecules in the block of
metal but that isn't the macroscopic the
large scale motion of the of the block
of metal isn't the same kind of thing so
the relationship between the large scale
motion and the small scale wiggling
around of molecules is a very subtle
thing and that's the thing called the
second law of Thermodynamics maybe I
should explain the um uh well the the
the yeah there there sort of three or
four common laws of
thermodynamics um the first law
basically says that energy is conserved
you can have energy that's in the
overall motion of things you can have
energy that's in the microscopic motion
of molecules but if you add up the
energies of those things it'll always be
a constant you can't without sort of
adding stuff from outside the system you
can't change the energy of the system
that's the first law of thermodynamics
the second law of Thermodynamics says
what was originally energy associ with
large scale motion gets ground down into
energy associated with small scale
microscopic motions so let's say you've
got friction you are you're you're
rubbing two things against each other
that's a large scale motion but the
effect of that is they get heated up you
know microscopically what's happening is
the molecules are getting pulled around
and each individual molecule is getting
is doing its little thing and in the end
what was kind of large scale very
organized motion of just rubbing the two
blocks of metal turns into small scale
disordered motion and that's the
phenomenon that large scale motion tends
to turn into small scale motion that
sort of and that's an irreversible thing
once it's heat it doesn't suddenly the
molecules don't suddenly arrange
themselves so that the block of material
so that all the molecules go the same
way at the same time and the block of
material sort of takes off running in
One Direction it's just stuck in this
sort of random motion so that phenomenon
of the fact that you get from sort of
organized motion it's it's sort of
ground down into random motion that's
the second law of Thermodynamics the
tendency towards sort of randomness of
motion um that that was the originally
formulated version there's a much more
General version of that that's really
about the fact that simply simply
defined initial conditions tend to
become more random it's something I've
studied for many years and I just wrote
this book actually about the second L of
thermodynamics that um is uh um
is is is is I think finally an
explanation of how this all works that
people have been really confused about
actually for 150 years so it's kind of
cool to be able to unravel that and see
how it really works but that's that's a
different thing the for for these
purposes the second law just says large
scale motion grinds down into small
scale microscopic motion that's Heat by
the way just for for fun I can say the
third law of thermodynamics is the
statement that it's really hard to get
to absolute zero that you really there's
enough Randomness in all that motion of
molecules that if you want to take heat
out and you want to just get those
molecules to all be sort of stationary
that you kind of have to poke every
molecule separately it's in a finite
number of steps it's not possible to get
to absolute zero and that that has the
Practical effect that you know there are
all kinds of schemes for refrigeration
that get you to micr Kelvin even I think
Nano Kelvin now within a millionth of a
degree degree Centigrade from absolute
zero or even a billionth of a degree
centigrade and those things have um
those things are are are sort of
fighting the third
oramics there's also by the way a zero
FL of thermodynamics which is the idea
that there is a concept of temperature
and the idea that if you have a block of
metal and it that there's a single
temperature that that all the molecules
are wiggling around with about the same
kinetic energies in different parts of
that piece of metal after enough time
that eventually the piece of metal comes
to equilibrium that's that's a very r
introduction to thermodynamics I mean I
will say that there are all kinds of fun
things like there's the notion of
negative temperature normally oh I I
should say that in when there's when I
say the average kinetic energy is this
or that there's actually a distribution
of kinetic energies they're not all
they're not all the same there's a
distribution it's always e to the minus
the ktic energy divided by KT the
temperature that's that's the there's an
exponential distribution and so normally
things of higher kinetic energy are less
likely um but there's this notion of
inversion that happens in lasers for
example that effectively corresponds to
negative temperature because you'll have
more things in that higher energy State
than in the lower energy State and
that's a a sort of thing not really
covered in th dyamics but that's a
that's a sort of related phenomenon
anyway that's um I don't know whether
that was helpful in um uh
um in kind of uh intro to to
thermodynamics but but the you know what
happens in thermodynamics there is um um
you know that that's kind of the
difference between heat and temperature
um macroscopic all the the the whole
energy versus the individual molecules
uh energies um there's a in in
traditional thermodynamics there are a
lot of relations between heat internal
energy work that's mechanical motion
type things pressure
volume uh temperature etc etc etc and uh
uh it's it's a it's kind of all very
useful if you're doing chemical
thermodynamics or engineering
thermodynamics or hbac systems or
something like this it is a little bit
confusing with respect to how it all
works microscopically because it's
really very it's a sort of a simple
mathematical theory that sits on top of
kind of a a the foundations of it are
kind of complicated but once you have
decided that things just work according
to let's say the second law of
Thermodynamics once you've you've bought
into the second law then you can reduce
all these mathematical
relations all right we should probably
wrap up here uh just to mention I I've
um uh it's always fun for me to give
these explanations I have to say that
you know many of the things I talk about
here you know i' I've known about these
things most of my life and I don't think
I've ever explained them to people so
it's it's really fun for me to um uh to
have a chance to try and explain them
and and uh um see see how well I can
manage to sort of get to the end result
without having to sort of yak about
fancy math and things like this uh just
one one thing I might mention I I've
been this explaining things U as people
may know there's a a total solar eclipse
I happen to mention that earlier in
different context that's coming up on
April 8th and of this year visible
across the US and um I in in sort of
recognition of this I had done some work
back in 2017 when there was another
total solar eclipse kind of tracing the
uh the history of how one predicted when
an eclipse would occur and we put up a
website that predicted to the second
when the eclipse would arrive at a
particular place we're going to do that
again in April of this year and I have a
little book that I put put together
about sort of how Eclipse how one
predicts when eclipses will happen and
that book I think is coming out like
this coming week uh ahead of the eclipse
you know you you can't uh you can't um
dilly dally because the the Sun and the
Moon they move as they move and the
eclipse will happen on April 8th and
there's none of this oh whoops we're
late you know let's let's postpone the
eclipse it's going to happen when it
happens so we kind of have to get our
book out in time and it's coming out
next week so I I just wanted to mention
that and maybe maybe in one of these
live streams I can talk a little bit
about the theory of eclipses and uh and
how one predicts them and so on and
maybe a bit about the history of of how
that was figured out all right well
thanks for for joining me and thanks for
asking lots of interesting questions and
see you another time bye for
now